after i got hurt it was painful to sit
on the sidelines and watch other people
play sports and participate and
not be involved
when i started this interest in
photography
it was an opportunity to get back into
sports again
my name is lauren worthington
and i'm a photographer
when i was 21 years old i wanted to be a
baseball player i was playing one
evening
and i hit a great double that was a
lousy triple and i slid into third base
came in contact with
the other player's knee and it pinched
my spinal cord the result of that was
paralysis i'm a c56 quadriplegic i've
been in the wheelchair for the past 30
years
it wasn't until almost 20 years after my
injury that i picked up a camera
adapting the camera is kind of an
extension of learning how to deal with a
disability
i cannot use my right fingers what i
figured out is that i could use an
external shutter control with my mouth
and take the photograph
the type of photography that i do
is about people who are involved in
adaptive sports
i felt my best photographs were of
people with disabilities because
they
saw in me somebody that they could open
up to
when i take photos of athletes i want to
show them as somebody who
works hard who competes hard and who
wants to win
that really shows more about the athlete
than the disability
when i first started shooting adaptive
sports i immediately set my goal to
taking photographs at the paralympics
i got the phone call from the united
states olympic committee that they were
interested in me going to rio de janeiro
in 2016.
there was some of the most amazing
athletes there and it worked out same as
what i've always had to deal with is you
just got to try it probably the first
day it's not going to work so well but
after that you just start getting better
and better at everything you do
is the canvas and the light is my brush
with light painting you can create new
worlds in the darkness
my name is hanuktamo and i paint with
light
i live in finland
we have amazing
nature here
we have long summer nights that are warm
and full of light
but on the opposite
there is also this dark part
it's called polar night
it starts in december
and it lasts for about 50 days
the sun doesn't rise above the horizon
at all
and
for a light painter that is quite good
i do long exposure photography which is
a photographic technique
that allows me to draw with light
the exposure times can vary from seconds
to hours
and the idea is to use the light sources
as the brushes or pencils
and the dark surroundings are the canvas
when i start i might do some sketches on
paper
after that
i go to the location
i search for details that i want to
emphasize
with some light treatment it will start
to look like a completely new place
going to a dark woods
or to abandoned house you first think
that oh i don't want to go there because
there's just so nasty looking dark
places but through light painting i have
examined these places
and
they look beautiful
you see the place differently
light is very powerful for me
yet it's also something that i'm
desperate to hold on to
it's going you know the lights are going
out
so i'm struggling to hold on to the
light
i was in art school in 79 and the eye
doctor said mr era you have an eye
disease you will be blind in 20 years
and i said what
you're telling me this bad news i'm
going to make the best art i can ever
make god damn it you know i'm going to
do it
i see very bright lights
and i can't see dim light at all i've
never seen a star in my whole life
for example i was looking at that view
towards manhattan what i see is a very
small area maybe about half the size of
my thumb
and all around that
it's not black it's not white it's not
gray it just doesn't exist
that's how i see everything else it's
just non-existence
there are a number of visually impaired
visual artists now and we do have a
facet in the art world
light painting is a process where you
use your mind as much as your eyes
it's a very long time exposure made in a
darkened room
with a flashlight
the person will be there and i will turn
off the lights and wherever i don't
paint with the flashlight it'll be black
in the picture
the fear i have about blindness is very
strong
it's a feeling that my life will not be
worthwhile if i can't see
but
as a totally blind person i will still
be able to do the light painting
so it is a comfort to know that my work
is strong
even though maybe in the future i won't
be able to see it
they're huge
i know it's like seeing a bus in the
water
and she looks at you with those big eyes
and she stares at you it feels beautiful
that's when you know that she's letting
you in
that's anwar patane
he's a photographer
and in 2015 he won the grand prize in
national geographic's traveler photo
contest for his photo whale whisperer
so we're talking about what it feels
like to come face to face with one of
the largest mammals on our planet
the first time he was in roca partida we
knew we were going to see the whales
because we were hearing them
and when they're nearby your whole body
resonates so strong
oh i love the sound of the whales it's
it's as beautiful as seeing
them he's under water and off in the
distance
i saw the silhouette of the whale
big big ceiling that looked like a
submarine without features it's just
like a big object and as he got closer
things became
clearer oh there's the eye there's the
theme
that's a big wheel
it's a very big wheel
the most profound feeling he had was a
connection to the whale herself
she looks at you right into your eyes
yeah
and you feel the connection now there's
a mammal connection
you feel accepted
anwar has been diving for 17 years and
his photographs are more than just
pictures most of the photos i make i try
to share them because people that
doesn't dive and doesn't know the ocean
they might start to pay attention to the
ocean
and i like wales
it's a reminder
that we share the world with
very very wise and beautiful animals
down there
you